a little beach yes a little billy Eilish
I think my head and my heart just
exploded
that's jungkook dancing and yes
lip-syncing to Billy eyelashes bad guy
the video was posted to BTS is official
Twitter account and are we surprised the
vid has already racked up almost 15
million views nearly 2 million likes and
800 thousand retweets we see you BTS
army and were impressed Lilly's bad guy
is only getting bigger just last week
Britney Spears posted a video of herself
dancing to the track are you ready for
the next level of superstardom no no I
think I am honestly no I think I I feel
like I feel like I am feel like I always
have been a little bit without really
realizing it it's your destiny but back
to BTS we know the guys are fans of
Billy who is like the dream for BTS to
collaborate with that would just kind of
like blow your mind
right
so basically we need this Billy BTS
collab to happen ASAP while we're
talking about kpop crossovers et just
caught up with tomorrow bite together
and they revealed they want to collab
with BTS can you imagine
look you guys would break the internet
break the world if we could get a
collaboration with BTS is that something
that could ever possibly maybe happen oh
yeah Mike maybe we want yeah yeah if we
can we want to have a collaboration with
BTS yeah they gave us lots of advice and
there's their like their performance is
really good and of course we we went to
Chicago to show off just yeah to see we
went to Chicago and met them there and
we saw their concert and it was really
amazing so much love in the music world
is happening right now I love it but
here's John Cook dancing to Billy it one
more time just because it's good all
right guys what did you love most about
the video what are the chances we will
ever get a BTS Billy collab let me know
and for all the latest on Billy and BTS
keep it locked to all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now